rodrigo buenas tardes gracias por el
convite a través de básicamente
incrementar en un 50% del auxilio brasil
un programa social entregado a unos 50
millones de personas humildes y muy
humildes con lo cual en las expectativas
por lo menos desde el centro de campaña
desde el eid bolsonaro debieran mejorar
junto a esto también habrá un subsidio
para los transportistas y hoon kim
sumado a estos dos una ayuda para la
compra de gas algo que también ha tenido
un incremento considerable debido al
cambio a las modificaciones del precio
del petróleo a nivel internacional en
suma una apuesta arriesgada el
presidente por sonados sigue que tuvimos
en cuenta las eventuales violaciones
constitucionales ocurridas para esta
sanción pero que por los momentos por el
por lo pronto le pueden redituar una
recompensa por lo menos en los sondeos
de opinión tengamos presente que las
elecciones en brasil son el próximo 2 de
octubre
y el partido de los trabajadores del
otro contrincante de lula da silva el
principal favorito las encuestas criticó
el movimiento pero finalmente votaron a
favor para no negar gasto social a los
brasileños este movimiento puede afectar
a la ventaja de lula en estas encuestas
en efecto el partido de los trabajadores
de izquierda que polariza las elecciones
y probablemente será el antagonista con
jane watson aro de derecha encontró en
esto una trampa una celada en la que no
pudo dar respuesta es decir un partido
que reconoció no podía votar en contra
de un programa de ayuda social y al
mismo tiempo reconociendo que con esto
estaba dando una contribución a
bolsonaro en todo caso los sondeos de
opinión coinciden en su mayoría en que
lula tiene alrededor del 40 por ciento
de intenciones de voto contra el 30 31
por ciento devolución a lo cual la
apuesta de evolucionar o puede impedir
que lula sea por lo pronto electo en el
primer turno del 2 de octubre y llevar
el duelo político hasta el 30 que cuando
habrá ballottage toda una carrera
contrareloj y contra la percepción de la
opinión pública habrá que ver si la
población brasil tiene un electorado de
casi 150 millones de electores se deja
persuadir por este plan social muy
efímero hay que decirlo
solo hasta el 31 de diciembre en otras
palabras un plan estricta o posiblemente
exclusivamente electoral volviendo
precisamente a este gasto aprobado
existe algún tipo de iniciativa legal
para revertirlo por intervenir en el
desarrollo electoral
hubo un par de presentaciones ante el
supremo tribunal federal pero por haber
sido estas impulsadas por pequeñas
agrupaciones una de ellas el psoe un muy
módico partido de izquierda y que por
otra parte hay en el supremo tribunal
federal es decir la corte constitucional
una disposición de no volver a enfrentar
al gobierno o por lo menos eso es lo que
trasciende aquí en brasilia
todo indica indicaría que estas
objeciones del momento no prosperarán en
la corte suprema y bolsonaro y su amplia
mayoría parlamentaria podrán consolidar
esta victoria por lo pronto insisto en
el plano jurídico y eventualmente en el
plano electoral señor piña ti muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros en france